hey everyone
welcome to direct path number eight if
you haven't yet
tune in to the first seven direct path
videos i'm specifically
making this one like drill sergeant
style
concise precise to the point
our intention that we're gonna set is to
self realize
that means to god realize that means
to literally become one
as a union with god with source with
infinity with non-duality embodied
experientially
and this has incredible pragmatic
benefits
downstream like
effortless action as lao tzu said woo
way
in terms of the absolute highest
channeling
through for the greatest morality
to weave in to the social
fabric of our existence
maximize your own well-being maximize
your family's well-being society's
well-being
there are a tremendous amount of
pragmatic benefits
to self-realization it is the greatest
service that you can render our world
as i've said in the other videos place
yourself in a comfortable
location preferably where there's no
noise where you can sit comfortably
undergo a process of stilling your mind
relax your awareness
take deep breaths
pause the recording if you need to in
order to
really relax your awareness pause
as you need
to steal the monkey mind
alright so first of all we need to stop
the fluctuations of the mind this is
also known as
yogas
again the yoga sutras of patanjali 2
000 years ago if you're going to
go on this path of self-inquiry of
self-realization
of self-abiding look at the perennial
wisdoms across the mystic traditions
and in this case yogas chitta vritti
nirodha
literally means union equals
consciousness waves
quieting so yoga
is to stop the fluctuations of the mind
yoga means union to have a union with
god you need to stop the fluctuations of
the mind
and that's when the mind dissolves
itself
into consciousness into the infinitude
into the eternity of what this is
the temporary finite contracted
mind dissolves
and it takes the practice especially
when one finds oneself in a more
depressed or negative or anxious
state to recognize that
accepting oneself and loving oneself is
exactly what's going to
enable those fluctuations to stop
accept yourself and love yourself
radiate that from
your heart for yourself and for everyone
that is what is called metta that is
what is called loving kindness
now as that cessation of the
fluctuations happen
you're going to have this experience of
recognizing what is called
bear awareness
the most simple way to understand that
is to look at the sheet of paper
the sheet of paper without coloration
meaning without the words you're going
to recognize that the words themselves
are the experiences the words are the
emotions the feelings the thoughts
the experiences the objects
that is also another analogy for this is
the ocean
so all of those are the waves similarly
again
the words are like the waves
which are also like the clouds
or also like the applications on the
device
versus the pure bear empty awareness is
like the paper
it's like the screen it's like the sky
and it's like the ocean so you
are the oceanic-ness you begin to
understand more and more that's what's
meant by the flickering of the light
bulb
that is what is meant by the satori that
happens
and then that stays on that's
enlightenment when you
have completely dissolved that
contracted
sugar cube of the mind
into the oceanic infinitude
and as that contraction dissolves
it becomes more and more clear that
the pure bear empty awareness is eternal
it is
infinite it is home its nature is bliss
and peace
and then it gets colored by all these
words by all these clouds by all these
waves
by all these applications
and so you become clearly aware of that
juxtaposition you're no longer lost
in the experience or the thought or the
emotion or the feeling
or the object but you've now seen the
juxtaposition and you recognize it
and it enables you oceanically to
surf the crest of those experiences more
harmonically so that is
step two and then what that leads to is
step three
is that as you really anchor in the
realization
of what is god consciousness what is
infinity what is eternity what a source
that what happens is a tantric path
ends up unfolding which means
that you weave your self-realizations
into the social fabric
another way to say this sahaja samadhi
which means that
you gain your enlightenment and then
what you do is you carry
your enlightenment into the social
fabric itself
and it's a very natural effortless
action wu way
process that unfolds of where you
literally channel
only the absolute highest morality as
you undergo your daily societal
activities
so in a nutshell again our
intention in this one in direct path
number eight is like
a drill sergeant we want to get to the
core essence
of how we can compress this direct path
wisdom and have it transmit and our
intent
is self-realization to pierce the veil
of the illusory ego and to
have that sugar cube of the contracted
separate entity of the ego which has
all of its mind fluctuations happening
to have that dissolve into
the oceanic infinitude of pure bear
empty awareness
which then has that juxtaposition happen
where it can recognize
the eternal infinite nature of awareness
that is being colored by
all of the waves by all of the words by
all of the clouds by all of the
applications
and then we recognize that that process
is leading us to
ride more and more on the crest
of the surf
and in the now simply this
this now better and better
and then we naturally effortlessly
sahaja samadhi we take that in the
tantric path and we
weave our enlightened realizations
into the social fabric the absolute
highest morality so we
undergo a massive cleansing of our own
channel
as well as we butterfly effect out the
absolute highest
morality and peace and bliss and love
and compassion and well-being
and flourishing and architecting
abundance and prosperity
for everyone
that is the essence of the direct path
teachings
thank you i love you